BALLOON?
LAURA INGRAHAM HOST LAURA
INGRAHAM ANGLE.
SHE'S IN LONDON NOW.
SHE'S VENTURED IN THE PROTEST.
SHE TOOK THIS FOOTAGE HERSELF.
>> I DON'T THINK SOMEBODY WHO IS
SO SUCH OF A RACIST AND
MISOGYNIST SHOULD BE GIVEN SO
MUCH PROBLEM.
>> I THINK TRUMP IS HORRIBLE.
>> WAGES ARE UP.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN TO HISTORIC
LOW.
THE ECONOMY IS THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD.
>> I WOULDN'T ENTIRELY AGREE
WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: SAD PEOPLE AND SAD
COUNTRY.
ONE NOD SAT PERSON IN LONDON IS
LAURA INGRAHAM.
>> THE PROTESTS WERE KIND OF A
LETDOWN.
I'M GLAD YOU STARTED WITH THE
TRUMP BABY BALLOON.
THEY HAVE A TRUMP ON THE TOILET,
SAYING THINGS LIKE WHERE IS MY
CELL PHONE AND FAKE NEWS.
THAT WAS KIND OF FUNNY.
THE CROWD WEREN'T WHAT THEY WERE
LAST YEAR WHEN TRUMP WAS HERE.
IT WAS MASSIVE.
WE'RE GUESSING MAYBE 10,000
PEOPLE.
THE STRANGE THING ABOUT IT,
THERE WAS NOT REALLY A
SUBSTANTIVE CRITICISM SO MUCH OF
TRUMP.
HE'S A BAD PERSON KIND OF
CRITICISM.
IT'S MORE LIKE AN ORTHODOXY AND
IDEOLOGY OF THE LEFT TO BE
AGAINST HIM.
IT BECAME RATHER COMICAL.
>> KHAN WHO HAS BEEN IN DIRECT
SPAT WITH THE PRESIDENT, WHAT
HAS HE BEEN SAYING?
>> TRUMP VALUES AREN'T LONDON
VALUES.
WE TALKED TO SOME ACTUAL BRITTS
TODAY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN HERE, GREW
UP HERE 25 MILES OUTSIDE THE
CITY.
THE FUNNY THING ABOUT LONDON
TODAY, LOT OF BRITTS WILL SAY,
THERE'S NOT AS MANY BRITTS IN
LONDON.
LONDON IS A MECCA.
IT'S VERY CULTURALLY DIVERSE.
LOT OF IMMIGRANTS IN LONDON.
IT REPRESENTS IN MANY WAYS THE
MORE COSMOPOLITAN THINKING OF
U.S. CITIES.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT L.A.
REPRESENT ALL OF AMERICA.
OF COURSE NOT.
L.A. REPRESENTS L.A.
THAT'S FINE.
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP IN L.A. OR
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP IN NEW
YORK CITY OR BOSTON.
YOU GET LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE
LONDON AND THINGS CHANGE.
PEOPLE LIKE, THE ECONOMY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS REALLY STRONG.
WE KIND OF NEED MORE
INDEPENDENCE, WE DON'T WANT TO
ANSWER TO BRUSSELS.
TODAY SADIQ KHAN REPRESENTS,
TRUMP IS A BAD PERSON.
IF YOU SUPPORT HIM HE'S A BAD
PERSON TOO.
>> Tucker: THREE YEARS AGO THAT
BRITAIN'S VOTED TO LEAVE THE
EUROPEAN UNION IN THE MOST ACT
OF DEMOCRACY AND THEY'RE STILL
IN.
HAS ANYBODY NOTED TO YOU THAT
MAYBE THEIR DEMOCRACY IS FAKE?
>> I THINK LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
UPSET ABOUT IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN POLITICAL
TURMOIL LEADING TO TERESA MAY
LEAVEING ON FRIDAY.
UNLESS THIS THING REALLY HAPPENS
ON OCTOBER 31st AND BREXIT
HAPPENS WE'LL SEE ANOTHER
GENERAL ELECTION HERE IN THE
U.K. AND THEN WHO KNOWS.
WE MIGHT HAVE NAGEL FARAGE.
THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY WILL BE
OVER.
WHICH IS SAD.
IT'S OVER FOR THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY IF THEY CAN'T DELIVER ON
THIS.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY, OUR
COUNTRY WAS ONCE A COLONY OF THE
COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T HELP WHEN YOU VISIT
THERE MAYBE APPLICABLE LESSONS.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'VE SEEN
THAT INFORMS THE WAY YOU FEEL
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY?
>> AS MUCH AS WE COMPLAIN ABOUT
OUR REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY,
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE IS TOO
HARD TO ENACT AND WE'RE TOO
DISTANT FROM WASHINGTON.
THAT'S TRUE.
COMPARED TO THE PARLIAMENTARY
SYSTEM, IT MOVED AT A GLACIAL
PACE.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO BREAK THROUGH
AS FARAGE DID WITH THE BREXIT
PARTY.
BE GLAD YOU'RE IN THE UNITED
STATES WHERE EVERY FOUR YEARS
YOU HAVE MEANINGFUL CHOICE.
THEY'RE HAVING A HECK OF TIME
HERE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THE PARLIAMENTARY
SYSTEM.
I DON'T.
>> I'M OFF TO NORMANDY TOMORROW.